[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue dans ce sens public 90 minutes
de débats et de reportage pour donner du
sens à l'actualité grâce à nos experts
45000 policiers et gendarmes déployés
pour les festivités du 14 juillet le
gouvernement craint évidemment de
nouvelles violences ce qui a poussé
Emmanuel Macron à renoncer à la
traditionnelle interview télévisée après
le défilé militaire ce sera l'un des
thèmes il y en a d'autres vous verrez de
notre débat 100% politique et puis dans
trois quarts d'heure c'est l'histoire
d'un cheval de Troie que l'on vous
raconte TikTok réseau social préféré des
jeunes du monde entier soupçonnés de
servir de taupe à la Chine
cette entreprise serait particulière
fait preuve d'une telle opacité et ces
liens avec le régime de Pékin
apparaissent si étroit que nous
proposons dans cette commission sa
suspension pour des raisons de sécurité
nationale si à l'horizon du 1er janvier
2024 elle ne se conforme pas à une série
d'exigences légales et de transparence
minimale quant à son fonctionnement et à
sa gouvernance venez de l'entendre après
des mois de commission d'enquête le
Sénat lance un ultimatum à TikTok
propose de suspendre ce réseau social en
France et en Europe on verra quels sont
les risques en matière de sécurité
nationale de désinformation et de santé
psychologique des plus jeunes mais
d'abord on remonte jusqu'au 17 avril
quand le président de la République sort
du chapeau de ces communicants un
nouveau cap les 100 jours Fabien Ecker
était le 17 avril dernier pour tourner
la page de la réforme des retraites
Emmanuel Macron fixé une nouvelle
feuille de route autour du travail de la
justice ou encore de l'éducation et
donner rendez-vous aux Français le 14
juillet nous avons devant nous 100 jours
d'apaisement d'unité
d'ambition et d'action au service de la
France c'est notre devoir et je vous
fais confiance je nous fais confiance
pour y arriver mais l'apaisement
proclamé par l'Élysée n'a pas été au
rendez-vous à chaque déplacement le
président de la République est accueilli
par des casseroles au Parlement les
oppositions continuent de mener la vie
dure à l'exécutif en juin une
proposition de loi du groupe liote pour
abroger la réforme des retraites et
censurer in extrémiste par la macronie
mais c'est la mort de Naël tuée par un
policier à Nanterre qui achève de
plomber le bilan des 100 jours les
banlieues s'embrassent Emmanuel Macron
doit annuler un déplacement en Allemagne
il y a une instrumentalisation
inacceptable de la mort d'un adolescent
que nous déplorons tous alors que la
période devrait être recueillement et au
respect dans les colonnes du Parisien
Elisabeth borne apportant vanté le bilan
des 100 jours retraite travaille santé
les voyants sont au vert assure la
première ministre qui réunissait ce
matin les syndicats pour tenter de c'est
le dialogue social il y a des
préoccupations qui sont exprimées par
les salariés par les Français on avance
avec les organisations syndicales et
patronales une réunion intervenue alors
que la rumeur d'un remaniement occupe
tous les esprits sur la sellette en
particulier Marlène Schiappa discrédité
dans l'affaire du fond Marianne une
autre ombre au tableau de ses 100 jours
pas vraiment apaisé le bilan des 100
jours les risques d'émeutes ce 14
juillet la rencontre entre Elisabeth
borne et les partenaires sociaux mais
aussi on vient de la prendre en cette
fin d'après-midi l'interview donnée par
Laurent Wauquiez si le confrères du
Figaro dans lequel il évoque une union
sacrée autour de mesures fortes voilà il
y a beaucoup d'actualités politiques et
on en débat tout de suite avec Catherine
tricot bonsoir bienvenue bonsoir vous
êtes directrice de la revue regard
Thierry vaudel bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes chercheur
océipof Sciences Po spécialiste de la
communication de la politique Nathalie
Moret bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
journaliste politique au groupe Ebra et
Mathieu croissanto auditoris politique
bonsoir Mathieu bonsoir bienvenue à vous
allez on commence par le
100 jours je vais reprendre les mots de
Manuel Macron le 17 avril 100 jours
d'apaisement d'unité d'ambition et
d'action Catherine tricot le bilan
d'abord c'est très confus on sait pas
très bien ce qu'on va retenir des 100
jours bon il y a des émeutes qui
dominent absolument peut-être un petit
peu Marseille et pour le reste s'il y a
eu beaucoup de polémiques je sais pas
moi la polémique sont pétains la
polémique de autour de Marlène Schiappa
en fait il y a pas grand chose qui reste
de tout ça et en tout cas l'objectif de
rassembler d'élargir la majorité n'a pas
été atteint ça c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire et on voit pas qui est de
grands chantiers qui étaient lancé donc
pour moi je pense que ça n'a pas ça n'a
pas débouché on va dire ce qui est sûr
c'est que le premier mot de cette
déclaration le mot apaisement évidemment
a été balayé par ses journées d'émeutes
nos confrères de L'Express nous ont
appris que ce cap des changements il
avait été un peu improvisé juste avant
la locution du du 17 avril petit
rivaudel est-ce que c'était pour autant
une mauvaise idée de communication de
donner ce cas alors déjà l'expression
ouais l'expression fait référence
inévitablement au 100 jours de Napoléon
bon et puis ensuite c'est une expression
qu'on retrouve mais généralement utilisé
en début de mandat de quinquennat ou de
septennat pour annoncer qu'on va lancer
une nouvelle dynamique on va mobiliser
toutes les forces vives de la nation
autour d'objectif précis c'est ce qu'il
espérait faire voilà c'est ce qui alors
là c'est plutôt une relance parce que
bien sûr et l'autre chose aussi c'est
c'est quand même un exercice un petit
peu ambigu donc on pourra reparler du
message qui est pas du tout clair avec
une multitude d'annonces à la fois des
détails très techniques et des grands
objectifs rappelons-nous quand même les
trois chantiers c'est c'est quand même
intéressant
travail ordre progrès c'est de l'auguste
comte revisité travail ordre progrès et
très vague en même temps et puis en même
temps l'idée d'indiquer qu'on va faire
quelque chose en 100 jours
amène inévitablement appel véritablement
une évaluation mais oui
c'est peut-être un peu compliqué la vie
en tout cas ça a permis ces 100 jours
Emmanuel Macron de reprendre clairement
la main de d'occuper certains diront de
sur-occuper l'espace médiatique Nathalie
Moret pourquoi il a fait ce choix est-ce
que c'est un constat de faiblesse de son
gouvernement a constat de faiblesse de
sa première ministre pourquoi il fait ce
choix il avril
je crois qu'on oublie un petit peu dans
quel climat on était mi-avril mi-avril
il y avait plus feux de poubelles
absolument partout parce que le 49-3
avait permis l'adoption des retraites
Emmanuel Macron et l'ensemble de
l'exécutif était extrêmement démonétisée
donc il fallait que l'exécutif reprenne
la main et il le prend de deux façons la
première en disant en disant en
communiquant sur les 100 jours qui est
effectivement une ficelle un peu éculée
mais qui marche quand même toujours
jours puisque nous on y fonce droit
dedans et ensuite par une sur occupation
du terrain il est allé à Strasbourg pour
s'occuper de rien industrialisation il
est allé présenter le plan au je crois
que c'était en charente-marie non
c'était en dans les Alpes du Sud il a
fait les annonces sur l'augmentation des
enseignants vers Montpellier il a fait
une dizaine de déplacements beaucoup ont
été au son des casseroles puis de moins
en moins bref ça lui a permis de
reprendre la main
politiquement et finalement d'avancer
sur un certain nombre de chantiers c'est
à ça que ça a servi est-ce qu'il y a
aussi une part de regret Mathieu de la
part du président République à ce
moment-là de dire on lui a prêté
pour lui oui
un homme de regret il faut regarder ce
qui a changé pour essayer de voir aussi
le bilan on était il y a 100 jours en
plein conflits des retraites aujourd'hui
il y a plus de confilitres aujourd'hui
les syndicats les partenaires sociaux
étaient reçus à Matignon et ils en sont
ressortis
en applaudissements mais j'ai en tout
cas plutôt
différent une démarche constructive donc
de ce point de vue là les 100 jours ont
réussi à faire passer non pas à la
trappe mais dans les archives le dossier
des retraites plus personne n'en parle
ça veut pas dire que les raisons de la
colère ce sont effacées chez les
Français qui étaient opposés mais en
tout cas ça n'est plus un sujet
médiatique il y a eu ces annonces que
vous avez décrites il y en a eu aussi
sur le lycée professionnel enfin il y a
eu quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
chantiers qui ont été engagés alors
engagé c'est souvent des des chantiers
qui étaient préexistants et qui sont
ressortis opportunément pendant cette
durée des 100 jours mais qui lui a
permis d'occuper le terrain sur un large
spectre d'actualité
en revanche la situation politique n'a
pas changé c'est-à-dire que des textes
continuent d'être votés il y en a eu qui
ont été votés donc c'est vrai qu'elle
n'a pas réussi à élargir sa majorité
mais des textes ont été votés mais les
oppositions sont toujours aussi
remontées j'ose dire que ce soit à
gauche avec la nupesse ou à droite avec
les LR et au rassemblement national et
puis c'est son jour ont été percutés par
par ses émeutes il a fracasse un des
deux un des trois axes qui était ramenés
l'ordre public vous savez bah là on a vu
ce que ça donnait alors l'ordre a été
ramené quand même c'est vrai il faut le
dire pendant après 4 ou 5 jours de
d'émeutes dont une nuit ou la police a
quand même un peu perdu le contrôle de
la situation mais voilà c'est c'est un
bilan très contrasté avec un personnel
politique aujourd'hui inchangé puisqu'il
n'a pas remanié avec aucune de son
politique qui n'a été tirée puisque il a
fait comme si de rien n'était comme si
on pouvait enjamber c'est une expression
à la mode à l'Elysée alors faut-il voir
un lien il y a effectivement on va
reparlé dans un instant à un nouveau
risque de de violence urbaine à
l'occasion des festivités du 14 juillet
est-ce cette raison que l'Elysée a
annoncé qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'interview présidentielle après le
défilé de militaire on va en parler dans
un instant mais d'abord je propose un
Mathias ça reste de nous revoir on aime
bien régulièrement cette émission
notamment avec vous Mathias faire un peu
d'histoire et cette allocution du 14
juillet ça a pas toujours existé sous la
5e République non alors on aurait pu
penser que l'exercice aurait été inventé
par le général de Gaulle lui il aura
tort Thomas est bien non l'allocution
présidentielle du 14 juillet devenue
tradition républicaine nos datent que de
1978 et son instigateur n'est ni plus ni
moins que le disruptif alors on utilise
peut-être pas ce terme à l'époque Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing un discours qui s'est
perpétuer pendant des années et qui
venait donc faire le point six mois
après les vœux du Nouvel An nous
expliquent Arnaud Mercier spécialiste en
communication politique
au jour de l'an on annonce un peu le
programme de l'année le 14 juillet c'est
un peu le bilan on est à la moitié de
l'année à peu près et ça permettait aux
présidents de la République de faire le
point sur les sujets d'actualité faire
le bilan de de la législature écoulée et
de tracer de nouvelles perspectives
éventuellement pour dire ce qui restait
à faire pour le reste de l'année donc ça
c'est apparu pendant très longtemps
comme un moment un peu charnière on fait
le point des six premiers mois et on
fait le et on dresse le bilan pour les 6
mois à venir et pourtant tous les
présents la République ne se sont pas
prêtés à l'exercice ensuite non a été le
premier donc il en a fait trois avant de
perdre en 1981 face à François
Mitterrand le premier président
socialiste est aujourd'hui encore le
recordman de l'exercice 14 à son
compteur avec notamment un en plein
bicentenaire de la Révolution française
Jacques Chirac aussi à perpétuer cette
tradition républicaine 12 avec certains
mémorables après la dissolution ratée de
l'Assemblée nationale ou après la
victoire de la coupe du monde 98 il
avait alors salué une équipe à la fois
tricolore et multicolore son successeur
à l'Elysée Nicolas Sarkozy était moins
fan et a donc boudé l'exercice pendant
ces 5 ans à la tête de l'État en 12
François Hollande renoue avec le
discours du 14 juillet il en prononcera
5 et notamment le seul et unique en
dehors des murs du palais présidentiel
il avait été enregistré à l'Hôtel de la
Marine à l'occasion de sa dernière
allocution en 2016 François Hollande
avait aussi remarquablement recadré
celui qui était alors son ministre de
l'Économie incertain Emmanuel Macron
celui-là même qui ne reprendra
l'exercice à son compte que 4 ans plus
tard en 2020 pour nous parler de
pandémie et d'obligation de port du
masque le président de la République ne
renouvellera les secs en 2022 à la suite
de sa réélection un discours teinté de
guerre en Ukraine de crise énergétique
et de majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale et après vous quel message
envoie le présent République en
choisissant de ne pas parler le 14
juillet alors peut-être qu'il n'y a pas
de message enfin la séquence laisse
quand même penser le contraire et c'est
là encore une occasion manquée pour
Arnaud Mercier
c'est effectivement un petit peu curieux
puisque on ne pouvait penser que il
allait profiter du 14 juillet pour être
justement le moment de faire le bilan
puisque il avait tenu absolument une
fois que la loi sur les retraites avait
été promulgué à montrer qu'il était
capable de retrouver l'initiative de
faire voter des textes des lois des de
prendre des décisions et que c'était
sans doute le moment le moment de faire
le bilan de cette action
gageons qu'il le fera un petit peu plus
tard
Emmanuel Macron annoncé qu'il prendra
prochainement la parole mais les 100
jours eux sont bel et bien fini merci
beaucoup
Thierry Bedel est-ce que c'est has been
la locution ou l'interview du 14 juillet
non non pas forcément je crois que
chaque président décide un petit peu
d'efforts et des moments de ces
interventions quand regarder le schéma
qui a été présenté moi quelque chose qui
me frappait vous savez on distingue
souvent deux types de fonctions
d'exercice de la fonction présidentielle
le président arbitre qui est un petit
peu au dessus de la mêlée puis le
président capitaine qui est finalement
une sorte de Premier ministre et en
regardant ça on a l'impression que ce
sont plutôt les présidents arbitres qui
tirent les leçons qui qui
finalement remettre les bons points
d'une certaine façon qui favorise
l'intervention du 14 juillet c'est le
moment de l'année où on fait un petit
peu la remise des prix
en conclus des cohabitations c'était
aussi pour eux le moment de s'adresser
aux Français et de surplomber le
gouvernement et le septennat
renforce le la tendance on va dire du
président capitaine peut-être on
pourrait dire seulement
c'est à dire que si on voit François
Mitterrand il en a fait 14 chez ragd 12
c'est-à-dire exactement le nombre
d'années où ils ont été président ils
ont fait systématiquement un petit peu
la tradition par filiation
mitterrandienne Nathalie Moret Emmanuel
Macron va quand même devoir lui aussi
faire le bilan de ses 100 jours ça sera
peut-être dans la presque quotidienne
régionale c'est qu'est-ce qui est prévu
alors je vous annonce que pour l'instant
si ça a lieu dans la presse quotidienne
régionale je ne suis pas au courant
qui disent le contraire oui en fait les
gens les gens prêchent un peu le le faux
pour savoir le vrai etc ce qui est vrai
c'est que Emmanuel Macron avait prévu de
faire une intervention télévisée c'était
ce qu'on nous annonçait il y a une
quinzaine de jours en disant bien sûr il
y aura pas de problème il y aura une
allocution ou ou un entretien télévisé
mais il y a eu les émeuts de fin juin et
c'est vrai que c'est ça qui change tout
c'est ça qui bouleverse ce 14 juillet
soit le dans la soirée du 13 soit dans
la soirée du 14 donc 14 juillet soit le
13 ou le 14 mai toujours un petit peu
des émeutes
donc là ils ont peur que ça soit
effectivement encore plus important et
quel signal ça donnerait si
effectivement le président de la
République fait son bilan à l'occasion
d'une interview télévisée le 14 juillet
à l'heure du déjeuner et si le soir la
France s'enflamme c'est juste pour ça il
est en train de de effectivement de
décaler son bilan qu'il fera soit par
une allocution soit pour par une
interview je suis disponible s'il veut
me voir c'était aucun souci
de fébrilité c'est vrai que il n'est pas
obligé de le faire on l'a bien vu et
Mathias sa première appelé c'est les
présidents qui décident mais quand vous
donnez rendez-vous à quelqu'un et que
vous pointez pas le jour du rendez-vous
c'est quand même bizarre il y a 100
jours il a dit quand même qui tirait le
bilan 100 jours après et puis par
ailleurs c'est quand même passé cet
événement ces émeutes pendant 5 jours on
n'a pas eu de grille de lecture
d'analyse de la part de l'exécutif il y
a une interview d’élabeth borne qui
était d'une pauvreté intellectuelle si
j'ose dire du point de vue de l'analyse
de ce qui s'était passé
de son point de vue ce qui s'était passé
en France et qu'on ne l'est pas encore
le président pour l'instant on est
seulement dans la réponse sécuritaire
absolument je rejoins tout à fait
Mathieu c'est-à-dire une intervention
qui aurait été programmée le 14 juillet
en cas en effet des meute ou
d'événements violents d'une part ça
focalise la tension uniquement sur les
émeutes et ça ça détourne l'attention du
reste et puis dans le risque qu'il prend
le risque d'être accusé éventuellement
d'avoir mis l'huile sur le feu par un
propos maladroit où elle et ça oblige
aussi le président à interpréter les
événements ce qui n'a pas été fait là je
vous rejoins tout à fait c'est-à-dire
que jusqu'ici on l'interprète plutôt
d'une façon reflet de de violence
sporadiques ou réaction émotionnelle
mais il n'y a pas eu une leçon en
profondeur alors la réponse sécuritaire
c'était aussi le thème de la conférence
de presse donnée par le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin donc crainte
de nouvelles violences c'est très enfin
dans la soirée du 13 au 14 et dans la
soirée 14 il annonce un dispositif
policier renforcé on l'écoute nous avons
décidé de la mise en place d'un
dispositif exceptionnel puisqu'il
s'appuiera pour les 13 et 14 juillet sur
130 000 policiers et gendarmes agents du
ministère de l'Intérieur donc 45000
chaque soir spécialement équipés et
organisé pour procéder à la lutte contre
les violences urbaines selon les mêmes
modes Modus opéranzy que pendant les
quatre jours d'émeutes c'est-à-dire que
nous mobiliserons le raid le GIGN labeyi
les hélicoptères de la gendarmerie
nationale qui veulent dès le 13 juillet
bien sûr les drones qui ne permettent
comme on l'a montré pendant les émeutes
d'intervenir plus rapidement et j'ai
également demandé à la Premier ministre
l'utilisation des véhicules blindés
comme nous l'avons fait d'autorisation
qu'elle m'a donné et qui permettra donc
de prépositionner les véhicules de
gendarmerie dans les villes qui sont
apparemment les plus touchées Catherine
tricot c'est une réponse sécuritaire
encore une fois
oui mais il est indispensable face aux
émeutes face aux violents urbaine est-ce
qu'on peut
pas se contenter de ça
mais il faut commencer par ça en dehors
du premier jour où Emmanuel Macron a dit
c'était inacceptable et incompréhensible
dès le lendemain
une excusable qui avait beaucoup plus de
poids
mets le une explicable je ne me
l'explique pas qu'il puisse dire que
c'est une explicable parce que même
cette histoire là est quand même très
documentée on sait d'où ça vient
inexcusable ça lui a été reproché mais
depuis on dirait qu'il la retiré et puis
après on a plus rien eu comme
explications
l'interprétation la politique ne peut
pas être de déployer simplement des
chars des drones des des avions enfin je
veux dire ça c'est totalement
insuffisant le moyen ou sur le long
terme sur le court terme
[Musique]
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron prépare quand
même une réponse on va dire plus
profonde à cette nouvelle énième crise
des banlieues oui ils sont en train de
d'analyser et de voir qui sont de façon
très pragmatique qui sont les quatre
mille personnes les quatre mille jeunes
qui ont été interpellés pendant pendant
les émeutes qui sont-ils d'où
viennent-ils de quel quartier quel
profil
tout ça et ensuite parce que c'est
l'heure si vous voulez encore du
diagnostic il faut pas oublier que
les maires notamment ceux de ma zone de
circonscription où il y avait jamais eu
rien eu rien eu dans des villes où il y
avait vraiment il y avait pas d'histoire
il y avait pas de de quartier difficiles
les mères ont été complètement
tétanisé sidérée parce qu'il est arrivé
et ils l'ont dit au président qui a été
très attentif me distille à ça ça c'est
la première chose et ensuite je pense
que comment dire il y a aussi une étude
qui a été faite qui n'est pas sorti qui
n'était pas faite pour ça mais qui
disent du gouvernement du service
d'information du gouvernement qui dit
que un Français sur trois a été impacté
parce qu'il s'est passé soit parce qu'il
a de la famille soit parce qu'il connaît
la ville etc c'est beaucoup en français
sur trois et je pense que c'est ce
chiffre là qui explique les moyens de
les moyens de de qui sont annoncés
aujourd'hui par le ministère de
l'Intérieur c'est-à-dire que la
sidération a été tellement au-delà des
quartiers qui ont été touchés que je
pense que d'annoncer de tels moyens mis
à disposition demain et après-demain sur
le terrain c'est ce qui explique ça
alors ça n'exonère pas d'une réponse de
fond d'elle alors ça fait des
pratiquement 15 jours qu'on reparle du
plan Borlo est-ce que ce serait
reconnaître de la part d'Emmanuel Macron
s'il ressortissait le plan Borlo ma
phrase est alambiquée mais vous allez la
comprendre évidemment est-ce que ce
serait reconnaître son erreur de de sa
part je rappelle qu'il avait mis ça au
fond d'un tiroir c'est d'être en 2011
pour autant que le plan Borlo soit
adapté c'est-à-dire on a quand même
l'impression c'est ça la complexité on a
l'impression d'avoir à faire à des
événements
en partie inédit pas complètement
c'est-à-dire en partie on retrouve les
ce qui s'est passé en 2005 mon
impression que c'est à nouveau une
manifestation de cette crise 2005 mais
aussi par exemple la jeunesse des
participants qui interroge beaucoup
malgré tout et aussi les lieux où ça
s'est passé c'est-à-dire des lieux
inédits qui n'est pas connu forcément
pour être des lieux de violence donc ça
suppose une autre réponse et d'abord une
analyse en profondeur et qui peut pas
être faite très rapidement à mon avis et
qui peut pas se limiter non plus au
nombre d'interpellés parce que c'est un
indicateur un petit peu particulier
Catherine tricot je rappelle parce que
noter le spectateurs le savent pas
forcément que vous êtes architecte vous
connaissez bien ces enjeux de politique
de de la ville sur ce plateau il y a
quelques jours il y a un de nos invités
qui disaient
110 milliards d'euros dépensés depuis 30
ans où sont-ils passés alors vous je
savais que vous auriez d'autres chiffres
mais c'est toujours compliqué avec les
chiffres mais c'est une vraie question
c'est une vraie question comment cet
argent a été utilisé bien ou mal utilisé
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il a été bien
utilisé je pense que c'est un effort
exceptionnel c'est le seul pays au monde
à l'avoir fait bon la France a construit
beaucoup de grands ensembles et cette
partie de nos caractéristiques je dirais
à l'échelle mondiale mais on a quand
même fait un effort considérable donc je
pense qu'il faut le reconnaître et il a
suffisant non moi je pense pas qu'il
soit insuffis enfin il est insuffisant
on peut toujours dire qu'il est
insuffisant d'abord il est trop long
c'est-à-dire que la l'intérêt de prendre
des plans Borlo c'était de vouloir faire
des plans globaux c'est à dire qu'il
fallait agir sur tout sur l'espace
public sur le logement sur les
transports et que faire un projet global
ça prend du temps donc ça c'est bien une
première difficulté qui est le temps de
mise en oeuvre de ces plans et puis il y
a eu beaucoup d'argent qui ont été mis
sur ces quartiers là et moi je crois que
c'était nécessaire mais ce dont nous
parlons là ça va bien au-delà de ça ce
n'est pas qu'une question les les
émeutes qu'on vient de connaître n'ont
pas concerné comme en 2005 la grande
bande c'est que c'est donc on va bien
au-delà des questions d'urbanisme de
désenclavement de rénovation urbaine il
faut poursuivre ça parce que c'est le
minimum de dignité quand on va dans ces
quartiers on se rend compte qu'il le
faut mais ce n'est pas un problème
urbain à proprement parler c'est
vraiment enfin moi je crois une société
qui est profondément déchirée et qui est
qui donc appelle autre chose que une
réponse sécuritaire voire militaire bon
allez on veut non mais voilà vous le
redis
la temporalité on n'est pas tout à fait
d'accord mais on va pas à rouvrir ce
c'est encore une fois parce qu'il nous
reste beaucoup d'autres thèmes
passionnants dans dans notre débat 100%
politique et on va parler maintenant des
tensions on va s'intéresser à droite aux
parties LR les tensions nées de la
déclaration de Bruno retaillod ou le
président du groupe Bel-Air au Sénat
parlait de régression ethnique toujours
évidemment à propos de ces émeutes
violents sur Ben et elle était beaucoup
interrogé par des confrères sur cette
phrase
cette semaine ils s'en fichent donc on
lui reproche de copier le RN le patron
des sénateurs LR assume son coup de bar
à droite c'est pas le premier c'est pas
le dernier sans doute dans le discours
en tout cas souvenez-vous il y a quand
même quelques semaines le même Bruno
Retailleau avec ses compères le patron
du parti et Olivier Marleix se sont
homologues à l'Assemblée avec un dévoilé
des propositions pour mettre fin au
chaos migratoire cette expression
consacrée à l'extrême droite et belle
les propositions étaient décalquées sur
le programme de Marine Le Pen mais c'est
comme ça l'immigration c'est son
adaptable ou non Retailleau et puis les
autres on entend son selon lui dans le
déni c'est ce qui est d'ailleurs précisé
aujourd'hui à Public Sénat à la sortie
évidemment de de l'hémicycle donc voilà
il est persuadé que il y a que comme ça
que LR peut s'en sortir comme si la
droite n'avait jamais été assez à droite
ou comme si elle avait été un jour à
gauche il faudra quand même qu'il nous
disent quand et c'est où donc ils s'en
fiche il s'en fiche mais tout le monde
ne s'en fiche pas chez les républicains
il y en a un qui l'a recadré dans les
règles de l'art il faut le dire c'est
Aurélien Pradier qui fut comme erikiotti
vous savez son adversaire pour la
présidence de LR alors dans le monde le
député du Lot lui n'y va pas par quatre
chemins je n'accepte pas les propos de
Bruno Retailleau sur la régression
ethnique dit Aurélien Pradier le goût du
politiquement incorrect la parent
intellectualisation des mots de la
société ne peuvent pas justifier de
dévoyer nos valeurs fondamentales
insiste-t-il c'est là une limite
infranchissable si nous ne voulons pas
que la droite disparaisse ni Charles
Pasqua ni Philip Seguin n'aurait toré de
tels propos ils auraient été ferme sur
le rétablissement des valeurs et de
l'ordre républicain mais jamais il
n'aurait basculé dans un réveil de
guerre des races ce qu'il a raison du
point de vue de l'histoire et des
valeurs il a plutôt raison Aurélien
Pradier il faut le dire même s'il y a eu
des dérapages au RPR et on s'en souvient
mais il y a aussi raison d'un point de
vue tactique et c'est aussi ce qui dit
dans son interview au Monde car ce qui
se joue derrière cette bataille de
petites phrases c'est l'axe de
reconstruction de LR pour Bruno
Retailleau la droite ne doit plus avoir
honte d'être de droite si elle espère
l'emporter quitte à Saint-Germain
national on l'a bien compris c'est un
petit refrain en fait à droite souvenez
vous code à chaque fois que la droite en
période de crise ben nous ressort ça
Jean-François Copé l'avait fait après la
défaite de Nicolas Sarkozy en 2012
c'était sa fameuse droite décomplexée il
fallait arrêter d'avoir honte d'être de
droite mais pour les opposants à la
ligne Retailleau Aurélien pradé en tête
cette stratégie n'a pas d'avenir car
elle rend le LR monomaniaque sur les
questions d'insécurité et d'immigration
LR qui est par ailleurs aphone sur les
questions de politique économique
puisque Emmanuel Macron même la même
politique qu'ils auraient mené et puis
qui est carrément dépassé sur les
questions de société on le voit bien à
chaque fois ils sont contre les grandes
évolutions sociétales il avait été sur
le pack il avait été sur le mariage
homosexuel et puis à chaque fois
quelques années après ils disent non
mais finalement pourquoi pas donc pour
cela l'avenir que propose pour une
Retailleau c'est une droite réduite à
une tête d'épingle qui ne peut que faire
fuir ses franges les plus modérées et
donc se tirer une balle dans le pied et
puis il y a peut-être une troisième voie
dessinée par Laurent Wauquiez qui
appelle à une union sacrée autour de
propositions phares mais de proposition
phare évidemment très à droite sur la
sécurité sur les migrations sur la
méritocratie républicaine et sur la
fermeté dans la justice effectivement on
voit le titre de interview a publié en
cette fin l'après-midi de mercredi par
nos confrères du
Figaro Nathalie Moret s'intéressant
parce que Laurent Wauquiez vous on
travaille pas un secret vous l'avez
rencontré il y a quoi il y a deux jours
est-ce que il essaie entendre cette moi
je le vis je le lis pardon
peut-être c'est un peu simpliste mais
comme un appel du pied
à Emmanuel Macron est-ce que vous
sentiez ça alors pas du tout
enfin le plus important dans son
interview c'est vraiment sa lecture des
émeutes qui se sont passés en France il
y a 15 jours et ça effectivement je
retrouve assez la conversation qu'on a
eu
Laurent Wauquiez il est pas vraiment
actuellement dans la dans la tambouille
LR c'est plutôt quelqu'un qui essaye de
s'en extraire et de prendre un petit peu
de de la hauteur c'est-à-dire que il est
pas d'accord avec tout le monde à l'air
je je trahis pas de secret mais en même
temps quelque part il en a besoin
puisque c'est c'est sur eux qui qui
s'appuiera s'il décide de se présenter
en 2027 donc j'ai plutôt un sentiment
qu'il est dans la stratégie de la carte
postale de ne pas se faire oublier parce
que on est dans une époque médiatique où
tout va très vite ou effectivement
Aurélien pralier lui a pris une place
médiatique importante en plus
importantes que sa place au sein de LRD
absolument mais vous savez ce qui compte
beaucoup c'est c'est la surface
médiatique que chaque personnalité
politique a
et Pradier même s'il est dans une
minorité de LR il est quand même très
important aujourd'hui et il a 10 ans
moins que Laurent Wauquiez donc Laurent
Wauquiez je pense que ce qui fait là au
Figaro c'est la stratégie de la carte
postale en disant coucou je suis là on
ne m'oublie pas et effectivement en
faisant ce genre de petites phrases mais
on est à peu près sûr d'avoir 48 heures
de débat derrière et c'est ce qui je
pense c'est ce qui cherche autour de
leur ok nous on n'avait pas prévu d'en
parler évidemment cette interview on
l'évoque c'est normal c'est un événement
important de l'actualité politique au
moins pour 48 heures vous nous dites on
verra on pourra en juger parce que dans
cette interview si on va un peu plus
loin il dit à un moment ni coalition ni
négociation ni compromission tirevelle
comment vous l'interprétez cette cette
interview de Laurent Wauquiez est-ce que
ça le place
dans la ligne de ce que Nicolas Sarkozy
défend depuis des mois en fait depuis
les jours qui ont suivi le résultat des
élections législatives pour moi c'est
d'abord le reflet d'une crise de
leadership parce qu'on a quand même une
bien sûr avec les républicains
c'est presque une tragédie c'est à dire
jusqu'à l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron est
représenté à peu près le quart de
l'électorat et un électorat assez fidèle
mobilisé très attaché à certaines
valeurs et en gros pour résumer
conservatisme social et libéralisme
économique et puis il y a eu l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron et aussi le la
croissance du rassemblement national qui
a finalement fait éclater et ils sont à
la recherche d'un corpus idéologique
alors ils ont beaucoup de difficultés
pour s'entendre et jusqu'à présent et
très souvent c'était un petit peu comme
ça que ça s'était passé avec Chirac
c'est une personnalité forte qui arrive
à griver un petit peu toutes les forces
malgré leurs différences parce que
rappelons-nous au temps du RPR il y
avait pas une cohésion totale sur le
plan idéologique mais la personnalité du
chef du leader faisait que on se
rassemblé et là je crois que c'est c'est
le problème actuel des des républicains
c'est il y a pas de leader fort et c'est
ça leur grosse difficulté et en revanche
il y a beaucoup de candidats au
leadership un chef doit savoir j'ai fait
c'est ça c'était c'était Jacques
chiracle
c'est qu'en fait ce que je retiens moi
dans son interview c'est le premier mot
c'est à dire l'Union nationale et je
pense que c'est ça qu'il essaie de
donner de la hauteur de prendre de la
hauteur et de répondre finalement à
quelque chose qui est un peu dans l'air
du temps c'est-à-dire que on a tous on
fait tous une analyse éventuellement
différente sur comment recoudre la
société mais le caractère éclaté en
tension au bord de vraiment de la crise
de nerf de la société française je pense
qu'à peu près tout le monde le constate
et que donc il faut trouver des sujets
qui vont rassembler et recoudre la
société et c'est ça qu'il propose qui
dit union nationale alors après
évidemment il le colore à sa manière
immigration sécurité voilà donc je pense
que ça n'a aucune chance d'aboutir et je
ne crois pas qu'il veuille aboutir
d'ailleurs parce que je vois pas
pourquoi il irait faire une alliance
avec Emmanuel Macron au moment où le
gouvernement est au plus bas et que en
fait ce qui se joue c'est la relève à
Emmanuel Macron fallait la pré-emmanuel
Macron donc je crois pas qu'il veuille
réussir cette alliance par contre ce qui
dit c'est union nationale et donc en
faisant cette proposition il essaye de
d'émerger un peu au-dessus du marigot de
toutes ces petites histoires et moi je
voilà c'est mon interprétation c'est que
il essaie de se pousser du col pendant
ce temps la Marine Le Pen en grand je
popularité en hausse selon le baromètre
Ipsos du magazine Le Point regardez ces
chiffres 37% de la vie favorable une
hausse de deux points je crois que c'est
par rapport au mois de mai que la
comparaison était faite et sur les avis
défavorables c'est assez intéressant de
voir aussi que ces avis défavorbes sont
en baisse de trois points Nathalie Moret
c'est peut-être la la grande la grande
affaire des quatre prochaines années
parce qu'il y a cet après-midi on
discutait à la rédaction de de Public
Sénat de sens public et on se disait
mais Emmanuel Macron on a l'impression
qu'il est à un an de la fin de son
mandat il y a ce climat un peu
un peu particulier et donc l'un des
enjeux de du second quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est de ne pas finir
comme Barack Obama c'est à dire avec un
successeur populiste je pensais que ça
peut être ça peut être un petit objectif
à la rédaction publique c'est là mais on
je la partage aussi c'est un impression
qu'on est dans un moment de flottement
souvenez-vous quand il a été élu rééluia
un an on a eu un espèce de flottement
comme ça jusqu'à la création le
gouvernement la formation du
gouvernement borne et c'était
complètement lunaire on s'était il y
avait il y avait pas de texte de loi il
y avait on était dans un espèce
d'entre-deux j'ai le sentiment que
depuis 15 jours c'est-à-dire vraiment
depuis encore une fois ce moment de
sidération qui qui est comme ça enfin
qui a filé dans toute la société on vit
ce moment là est-ce qu'on va avoir un
remaniement ou pas est-ce que il va
parler ou pas est-ce que ça va reprendre
ou pas ces émeutes on est comme ça dans
un moment
il faut absolument qu'ils reprennent la
main donc moi je l'engage à reparler
très très vite et c'est effectivement un
moment particulier et il faut c'est à
lui c'est en tant que maître des
horloges c'est-à-dire c'est lui qui fait
qui donne le tempo de la politique
française doit reprendre le récit et
pour l'instant on n'a pas adressé on va
parler d'Elisabeth borne qui a rencontré
les partenaires sociaux aujourd'hui pour
conclure ce débat mais je voudrais quand
même vous entendre sur sur Marine Le Pen
Thierry Bedel parce que cette petite
musique d'une marine Le Pen favorite de
la présidentielle on est à 4 ans de
l'échéance et est-ce que c'est une
planche d'appel comme on dit en
athlétisme ou est-ce que ça peut devenir
un boulet aussi à force d'être la
favorite que tout le monde sort dans
toutes les conversations éternellement
enfin j'en suis pas sûr ce qui me dites
plutôt plan je l'appelle que vous voulez
mais vu par qui vous dit savez mais vu
par qui est-ce que le fait de
continuer débats après débat de dire la
séquence profite à Marine Le Pen elle
grimpe dans les sondages parce que
finalement ça va lui servir de tapis
rouge jusqu'à ce qui est bien plus
important que de le dire c'est de
regarder exactement en effet la
structure de l'opinion et de voir qui la
soutient et tout ça on le sait depuis
longtemps ça fait de nombreuses années
c'est une grande partie des catégories
populaires des jeunes aussi il faut le
dire qui soutiennent Marine Le Pen et il
y a une croissance plus ça c'est
entretenu par une stratégie suivie par
le groupe rassemblement national qui a
une stratégie de ils veulent des
diaboliser et vous répondez pas à ma
question est-ce que le fait d'être le
favori éternel ça peut finalement des
des jouets les pronostics les favoris 80
avant sont jamais les présidents
on n'en sait rien pour l'instant
on peut
améliore son image auprès d'un public
auprès de nombreux Français oui mais le
rassemblement national se fracasse
toujours dans les élections sur son
programme
c'était le cas sur l'image quand c'était
Jean-Marie Le Pen sur Marine Le Pen
c'est sur son programme qu'elle se
fracasse à chaque fois ça a été le cas
en 2017 ou d'ailleurs dans son débat
avec Emmanuel Macron avait montré le
vrai signe de faiblesse ça a été le cas
aussi d'une certaine façon en 2022 où
son programme n'a pas convaincu au-delà
de sa personne est là pour l'instant en
terme de programme le rassemblement
national ne fait rien donc alcoolis son
image un mot de réponse peut-être
Catherine rapidement et on parle pour
autant que le programme soit important
dans le dans le cadre du rassemblement
national je suis pas complètement sûr et
ce qui est important l'indicateur que
l'on observe le plus c'est il faut leur
donner leur chance dans les enquêtes etc
parce que on a tout essayé et c'est ça
et ça ce pourcentage il augmente
régulièrement allez et moi j'ajoute en
terme d'inquiétude c'est qu'en fait ça
sa composition sociale la composition
sociologique de son électorat devient
national c'est-à-dire que ce n'est pas
simplement les catégories populaires on
a les classes moyennes voir les classes
supérieures qui commencent à sombre
généal
locaux c'est-à-dire aussi en terme de
catégories sociales c'est à dire qu'on
trouve
rassemblement national
progression dans toutes les catégories
de la société et ça pour moi c'est très
important et très inquiétant au-delà de
la question du programme en effet c'est
l'un des événements aussi importants de
cette journée politique et sociale la
rencontre entre Elisabeth borne et les
partenaires sociaux c'est à Matignon que
ça s'est passé deux heures pour lancer
les bases d'un nouveau pacte de la vie
au travail alors je vous propose
d'entendre deux réactions syndicales
quand même assez contrasté on va dire
d'abord la secrétaire général de la CGT
Sophie Binet elle nous ramène au 100
jours la réunion d'aujourd'hui marque
l'échec concernant des 100 jours
annoncés par le Président de la
République et donc ce que nous avons
engagé aujourd'hui le 12 juillet
c'est
une reprise en main qui marque le début
des quatre prochaines années nous
prenons la main et donc nous imposerons
désormais dorénavant nos ordres du jour
nos méthodes et nos contenus l'Inter
syndical se retrouvera fin août pour
débattre de la situation sociale et des
modalités de la rentrée sociale autre
réaction autre tonalité la secrétaire
général de la CFDT Marylise Léon
donc une réunion
utile qui nous permet enfin de d'avoir
quelques actes posés on a un
gouvernement et un président de la
République a beaucoup souhaité
qu'il y a beaucoup parlé sur les enjeux
de changement de méthode donc là on a eu
quelques éléments de réponse donc
c'était important qu'on est des actes
les actes posés c'est que il y aura bien
l'ouverture du négociation ou de
plusieurs négociations ça reste encore à
définir à la rentrée sur les enjeux du
travail
Catherine tricot je rebondis sur ce que
Sophie minet disait la CGT qui veut
dicter le calendrier après tout pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas laisser la main en
partenaire sociale on a vu par exemple
sur la le partage de la valeur au
travail qu'ils avaient réussi à aboutir
à un compromis qui va être pris
quasiment tel quel par législateur
pourquoi la République sociale c'est ça
donc en effet pourquoi pas mais surtout
elle peut le dire parce qu'il y a une
inter syndicale qui est assez soudée
c'est ça que moi je retiens aussi dans
son intervention c'est qu'elle dit on va
se revoir et elle parle au nom de
l'Inter syndicale donc on n'a pas il y a
pas eu la fin d'inters syndicale il y a
évidemment à l'intérieur syndicale et on
l'entend bien dans les deux extraits que
vous avez passé des personnalités des
tempéraments et des positions qui sont
pas homogènes la CGT ne pas devenue la
CFDT et réciproquement mais on a une
intercer syndicale qui a l'intention de
rester unis et de marquer le tempo et de
faire de mettre sur le devant de la
scène ses propres sujets donc je pense
que c'est assez intéressant Nathalie
Moret quand Elisabeth borne
convoque finalement cette réunion à
Matignon est-ce qu'on y voit un signe
qu'elle est confortée à son poste parce
que c'est pas facile d'être Premier
ministre ou première ministre parce que
c'est une espèce de montagne russe
permanente on y va les rumeurs de
remaniement avec ou sans Isabelle borne
je suis la chef du gouvernement
je suis première ministre et je
travaille c'est ça qu'elle fait juste
avant la réunion avec les partenaires
sociaux elle a réuni les principaux
ministres qui étaient en charge de la
transition énergétique pour faire le
donc on voit bien que sur un texte
important qui a été voté au Parlement
européen sur tous les dossiers elle est
là elle travaille et elle montre qu'elle
est la manœuvre effectivement pour elle
c'est une façon de faire pression en
disant je suis là et j'entends bien
rester elle pour reprendre son
expression on avait consacré une
chronique et il y a deux jours là-dessus
et ils avaient de bornes des livres je
délivre une auditels c'est pas la
meilleure expression politique mais
alors donc ça c'est son côté techno
efficace est-ce qu'elle en oublie de
faire de la politique d'après vous ou
pas du tout oui c'est des livres un
anglicisme voilà non je crois qu'en
effet elle fait le boulot voilà tout à
fait
sans trop enfin bien entendu on se pose
toujours des questions qu'on met à ce
poste là mais je crois que bon elle a
une grande force c'est-à-dire qui
pourrait la remplacer voilà je crois que
c'est ça sa force indépendamment de de
l'intérêt qu'elle porte à l'action
qu'elle mène je crois qu'elle est
véritablement impliquée dans les actions
qu'elle a force et la difficulté
d'Emmanuel Macron de faire émerger les
poids lourds si je compte aussi
pas parce qu'elle est irremplaçable oui
parce qu'il y a personne pour la
remplacer
donc quand il y a pas de cap politique
autant avoir une techno allez on termine
là-dessus merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vous dis à bientôt sur
public